the data pipeline is studies of data
processing steps
and
each step delivers an output to the uh
uh an output that is input to the next
step and it continues until the pipeline
is accomplished um
uh in some cases uh some steps may be
part but just ignore it for now so we
move the data through the pipeline and
get the result at the end
uh
data pipelines are consist of three key
elements as we know
resource processing step or steps and
the destination sometimes in some
articles they call destination sync
and um this the data pipeline enable
data from for example from application
to data warehouse from a data lake to an
anti
system or database
for example in the business i work it
helps
i need to i need at the end of the day
give some of the performance of doctors
for example message to them or
they need to see it on the application
that they use so i should prepare data
for them it's one of the examples or
maybe
when a doctor want to prescribe
something
it's search a drug or service or a brand
of a
medicine so it needs a recommended
system also data should be prepared for
this recommender system also it needs a
for example a pipeline and
the most important part of
i think every business is the finance
each month i have to have data
uh performance of each province in our
in country for uh for managers so for
for these three examples are what i what
i worked with for for for the for the
first example every 10 minutes my data
should be ready
for the third example every month my
data should be ready
and then we see tools that do this for
us for example uh
in ibm or odi in oregon what we what
when we use these tools these tools
graphically are like a pipeline so data
starts from here goes esta pas and then
is ready at its destination so uh what
i'm trying to emphasize is that um
that really it's a pipeline even in the
tools uh and
maybe you are familiar with this
but for example in oracle you have a
very complicated tool its name is audi
in audi first we make a map in this map
we prepare the data then
a package of this map is markings uh
just a
major package then we put the package
together and data comes from package to
package and then
then at the end is ready these packages
can be sequential or parliament and then
at the end we have a certain schedule
that this
fellow uh wrong
as we wish
what i'm trying to say is that this
map package is everywhere and but
if you ask me it's a little bit old also
in a
also in a new tools like nifi you might
uh
heard of a knife i apologize
we can
move data from source from social
destination from several source
destinations even knife when you see
graphical uh graphical part of uh knife
is dcc uh we see if we see the pipeline
uh
what happens in real world is that
the business have some requirement
because of this requirement and this
requirement in my business in the
business i work in can be for example in
medical intelligence dashboard a
dashboard which shows
uh
medically what is happening in a
prescription world or for example it
might also
also maybe we want to monitor hospitals
or managers in hospitals wants to
just check their performance performance
people who works in the hospital so
because of these requirements uh
i have to implement i have to develop
develop a pipeline so
this python can be uh can be bashed or
streaming today we are going to talk
about swimming but what happened in the
real world is that for implementing for
uh building this uh a pipeline we need a
stack of tools this is
the third layer the last layer and the
devops people actually work on uh work
on this part uh
because of importance of some tools like
uh or uh like um s park or kafka a
little bit talk about spark and kafka as
important tools
uh to build up uh the sme pipeline and
that i want to talk about uh so it is uh
what's happening in the real world you
have a requirement you have to build the
pipeline this pipeline is on data stack
um
a big data pipeline is a pipeline
can handle big data but you uh now is 2
220 we all know what is a big data big
data is uh
when we call data a big data when there
is a dramatic change in volume variety
and velocity of data
so today also we don't want to talk
about just pipeline we want to talk
about the big data pipeline because of
the velocity of the data because of the
velocity of a big data it's very
happening for streaming also because of
the volume of data value of data this
apartment that i'm going to experience
should be escalating of course and
i it should be escalated i will explain
it uh
uh more later at its place and also
because of right of big data the
pipeline i'm going to build here i'm
going to explain how to build should uh
handle uh many different types of
formats and data extraction eye
selection and science selection
uh estimate uh
okay so i i talked about uh data
pipeline big data pipeline and not
assembly data pipeline estimate data
pipeline fills data continuously from
source destination as it creates i think
i think it is the it is the main point
here uh
and if you are not familiar if you are
not familiar with estimating data
pipeline or you are you you for example
you are not a data engineer or you are
generally working in data world i should
tell you that if we
if we consider data and ocean
if you just take bucket of the bucket of
data
in
different sizes it's a batch processing
and if you have a
pipeline if you have a water pipe that
just move the data from the ocean to
wherever you want it's a it can be a
streaming data pipeline i think is a
good example a general and good example
for that
um let me walk through the history here
that uh
what happens what happens a few years
ago and
i still know in some businesses is that
we separate article
uh identical part of business uh
two
night jobs for example if i want to
prepare data i say okay is your
transaction that happens daily on
systems and okay i put it here i i i put
it aside and now i i want to
do i i want to build some
dashboard some do some predictions so i
have to prefer data but i do at night as
a quiet time i bring the data and
prepare it for for late next day so
like 10 years ago until now what we what
we do in
most businesses is that we prepare data
overnight and what happens the
businesses have accepted this
uh acceptance okay i
i have a data but it's for example uh 24
hours late
but little by little and and it and we
call it
we call it etl uh
etl data uh for uh
in fact analysis uh
it has some drawbacks and if you ask me
the the most important the most
important uh in fact drawback is that it
needs eskimo it needs a lot of resources
and also it's slow and you have to
monitor it constantly if one night
if one night two nights god forbid more
than two nights your data is not
prepared your dashboards your reports
are or
are late and it is not uh uh in fact
good for
at least for this decision making
uh little by little but a batch of data
sharing volume of data grew and demand
for falters
fault parents and
systems girl so
also at the same time distributed
architecture
uh
blossom with hadoop and cassandra and
the other
technologies
so because of this demand for more time
the data and then
spark
the
change
uh in fact uh we changed how we look at
uh data in uh in a
big way
and uh because export presented a
consistent api and
it could it
it could run on a cluster or a stand
alone so
as a as a as a developer as a developer
you had a
you could run your uh run your code
on on a small sk and then move it to a
uh cluster because uh export had this
uh
ability
so because because of all these changes
uh in a few years in in few years uh
demand for uh
to building a real real-time data uh
increase and increase and so we moved
from we are in fact moving from batch
processing to stream processing
as i told you
this presentation has to focus when and
how if i want to answer the question
when as i mentioned already uh if your
businesses if your business need a
timely data you should go for estimate
uh
for estimating uh
and also if
you have a massive onboard unbounded
data set uh that increase
a lot you should uh consider uh
streaming which as we know in many
businesses you know it's so common
and
and also
uh
if if you want to process data as it
arrives you don't want to store data you
want to process it along a way in the
event
data is moving you want to process it
you don't want to store it first and
then process it it is when we go when
when we go for
uh
streaming
something else that uh i should explain
here i i have two more uh two uh main
examples is one of uh doing assuming
unlocks and in uh
a prescription before i go before i
explain these examples let me have a
another general example when you
you can think of a batch processing as a
producing a movie
script is ready and is definite based on
it you
uh create a movie
and you can change it you can change the
script when it's done you can't if you
want to change it you have to do it from
the beginning it's it's what happening
is a uh
in a
batch processing if is somebody's here
who works in a as a works as a bi
engineer as a data analyst knows this uh
this part very well but but estimate
processing is like a episodic show
yes
we know there is we know the
story but during the episode we can
change it little by little it is what
happens
when you are in fact
making a
streaming pipeline
the first example
which which we are doing in a
prescription is a lux
when you have a complex business like
e-prescription which is based on
insurance health insurance you have to
use a a micro service based application
otherwise you are in big trouble so when
you have a micro service base based
applications these services talk
together communicate together and um
if something and maybe
if one or two of these services fail
that we will have a complicated
situation also
when you want to uh
when you want to um
the error find the box find the failure
you have to survey
a whole request of a flow so for that
for for this reason and more reason that
i i i didn't mention here
you have to have meaningful likes these
likes help you dislikes help you to
track track errors
uh okay
how do you track errors when you want to
track errors uh you do it by monitoring
by monitoring but visualizing and
also
with monitoring and visualizing you can
solving the issues
but you have many many
small or small services they talk
together all of them
produce logs and it's become complicated
so you go for as we know for to predict
errors because when you public errors
you can uh
filter your monitoring you can have a
better visualization and also you will
be ready for
solving the issues as we know
huge data complex pattern we go for
ml machine learning machine learning so
it is what we need in our large ml uh
data estimating so one of our cases that
we needed to go for estimated data was
uh uh
surveying and in fact
predicting uh and solving the problems
happens in our system with
what we do on our lives
the other example the other example is a
fraud prevention
uh when it comes to e-prescription
just
imagine this uh
so
somebody goes to doctor the doctor
prescribes something for uh for him or
her and
the moment he prescribes and killing
okay it's over it's finished
uh insurance guidelines are working on
this
on this uh
uh prescription and at least
at least they calculate the price
they do a lot of things but
at least they calculate the price for
this
we will have json big data of this
calculation and
the other actions that is done
and also be prevented from
some fraud of course
for example
if you are a pregnant woman some drugs
shouldn't be prescribed for you or your
insurance doesn't cover some services
they should be eliminated from your
prescription or they should be uh or the
the
insurance part uh
should become zero so
this fraud detection that at the at the
moment you should do some uh
some actions on the for example
prescription
uh you need a data estimate because you
need the data at the uh at the same time
also we can use for fraud detection but
but we should have a better reason for
for uh fraud detection to use the
estimate i will explain it later but for
fraud prevention uh we need uh
assuming data
and uh the second part that i i told you
that i want to focus on is how how we
should have a streaming data pipeline
um it is blueprint of uh
estimate data art architecture
we have like um five
uh tire
uh collection message queue final answer
in memory data store and data access but
this line-term storage is optional uh i
will talk about it uh
later um
and as i told you
uh because there are two imports
uh okay
if you ask me what are uh
uh which one uh are more important i
tell you that message hearing and aspire
are more important they are heart of
data extremely so because because they
are important and the importance comes
from two very uh good tools i will
explain about kafka and spark here a
little example so uh
the the rest of the presentation i'm
going to talk about this tire and also
when i when i reach to curing i will
talk a little bit about kafka of course
it's more complicated than that but i
just uh i uh simply fight
and also i talked about export as a very
good
extreme process tool
let me
go through the architecture by example
first of all collection tire when a
doctor prescribes a treatment or some
medication it is collected by some
services i call them eric services but
it is not it is a
uh all over the country uh doctors write
prescription and when they
collecting data and as the data is not
in the same service they are across the
country so uh i need a message queuing
also
there are some we are sure that there
are some answers on on prescription one
of them is calculating the price
and
in a long-term estrogen
we don't david i don't want to talk
about uh uh i don't want to talk about
this uh part here but just imagine that
when a doctor prescribes something for
you maybe it's based on the history that
you have so you so so in some cases
maybe you need to show some history to
the doctor and in every day
in a time in memory data
store tired prescription that are mere
second old they are
they are not too old uh
they may help you to for example um
build their uh recovery system like
think of it as a google search so but
when when when you search something the
recent history show up so
it is maybe it is what you have for
doctor so you need a in-memory data
store for recent data i explain it more
and also data access of course what
happens in the in the system should be
available for uh for the system against
doctors patients
hospital managers and
some people so uh
i just try to uh go through an example
uh for this um
for
this architecture
to apply for it better in fact uh
let me uh
when we want to
uh build something from scratch we need
some definition uh definition of the
real-time data
is that
designing a system that delivers the
information a client request at the
moment it's needed
it should have it shouldn't be
it shouldn't be necessarily at time
it should it should be prepared when uh
when a client request for it so it is a
definition of a real-time data so if a
client add data data is ready we call
the real-time data
maybe it's three minutes later four
minutes later or at the the same moment
the collection tire the collection tire
as a first tire uh
it's then the data enters to the enter
to the uh
the pipeline and it's very important
that how it's a pattern of this data
entry is request response whether you
say something on your browser it's like
it's very simple you request uh
something and then uh you will have a
response or publish subscribe pattern
entering data is publish a subscribe
pattern like
say youtube that publish something and
when you whenever you want you go and
have a data but
one way pattern when
the data is
the data is uh
generated but
you don't need a response or acknowledge
or anything request acknowledge is that
acknowledges that response but just you
want to tell that this happened for
example in marketing each click that
each click that
that the user do on the on the website
can just acknowledged by uh by system by
uh
by platform by a system and then you can
see okay what is a
propensity of uh
this user to buy something you can for
example calculate that and extreme
pattern is available data comes to your
pipeline from another stream so you have
another history the sa this this data
comes with your pipeline from another
state we call it an estimated pattern so
this collection tire can be one of those
one of these and based on one of uh each
one
uh and we may
implement this part
while you are
designing your collection tire you have
to take craft three
points escapability partners and also
lagging
i don't talk about them but if you have
questions we will come back to them
for uh for more detail
uh message queueing tire is the second
tire
in message in a message queuing uh is
line up messages in order to communicate
between two systems so your data comes
your data is ready you don't go to the
ends tire
you put it in a queue then
analyze it or process or do some process
on it
why we do this why we put the data in a
queue
and let's say one by one we do the
answers it's because um
it's uh
because that uh we don't want to
collection tire and as a spire effect on
each other
we don't want the effect energy we want
to the board is decoupled
for example maybe your ass tire is uh
disconnected or is it slow or slightly
slow so what will happen your data
gathers here a lot and then maybe a
crash happens so we want to decouple uh
decouple our services decouple our tires
decouple our applications so we use
we we use a
message queuing
um
core concept top message to him is like
the data produced
it stays on a uh on a broker on a
server on a node in a queue and then
then it's consumed
and then it's consumed it's it's uh
seems so simple but not really it is not
that simple
so if i want to summarize why why i have
to use message queueing in
in my pipeline is i want to decouple
producer and consumer
producer as a uh collection tire and
consumer as a uh
tire purchase and consumers are
decoupled extra consumer because
most of the time the consumer is slower
and than uh
that
producer so this slow consumer doesn't
affect on
produce and also you can
change for example
increase consumer increase producer a
decrease producer or do some changes on
consumer
without effecting on this on this layer
also if a consumer failed because they
are in the different nodes all over the
world all over the country it doesn't
affect the system
and okay if i change the architecture to
the collection higher goes to a broker
and the answer is
uh
there are many many points that you
should consider
uh when you want a
design a pipeline
in fact choose uh this uh choose and
design this shoes or design this uh
message queuing
uh tire but one of them one of the
important ones is how your message how
your message the type of message what is
your type of
message delivery for example
it is
at most once the message may get lost
but it never be released by the consumer
at least once a message will never be
lost but it may be released by uh
maybe by the consumer or exactly once a
message never
never
lost and read by the consumer once and
only boss you may say of course i want
always like exactly once
the message doesn't uh get lost and also
it's consumer just wants uh ready but it
a it is not case in some businesses and
also
because of the
complexity of it i think sometimes as
most months or at least ones are even
better for example in marketing
sometimes
if a message gets lost no problem there
are the other messages that can make the
the same point
so uh
if you want to choose
if you want to choose
which delivery uh very type
delivery type that you want to choose
maybe you should
answer some questions but
it all depends on the business you're
working
there are some questions that you can uh
reply for that for example
uh
maybe you say that okay i don't want a
message queuing part
so you should you should answer this
question what would be the impact to the
fraud for example your system or
protection business if the communication
between collection fire and isis fire
itself for a period of time what will
happen if this happens
so if your business can clear this
nothing happened to your business so
it's okay you shouldn't have a
message screen but if you but in this
business that you are in the i mean uh
e-health business in prescribing the
e-prescription business that you are at
least you are calculating the price you
you can't afford it you you your
messages shouldn't be uh
lost or more important how many days of
work of data can your system turret
losing for example if you had the ad
system you can say okay
for one or two days uh the ad doesn't
work or the the ad is not precise or
doesn't the target of the ad
is ambi uh has some ambiguity it's okay
but when you are for example working in
core banking it would be disaster
also the uh the
the next question that you should reply
to do your system with historical data
and i think for for example if your
system is a uh
is a detection fraud detection you need
history because it's based on a history
that the person and the or a
process has and also the the last
question what type of message delivery
semantic does that your system need uh
that uh
uh you should choose one of them uh uh
as a answer so uh
for message queueing uh for message
screen uh
part
if
you want to be
clear uh to choose it or not or when you
should choose which tool
or how you deal with it you have to
answer some questions some more
important one
are these
uh and kafka
kafka is a
what's usually used in big companies and
for
message query and
it has a three part producer
uh
broker and consumer and
uh some data some like some message in
the copical message if it is some
message you have to know which topic
topic is like
table you know
so you have to know a bit topic so you
have a so you have a topic you write
your data and topic and the consumer use
them whenever it needs and also once you
once you
write it in the topic consumer can edit
uh multiple time
so your topic is getting big and big and
big and we know when the data will
become big and big but we do we
use a partition so you can also we have
partitioning in kafka you purchase your
data and
do it
thoroughly or
because kafka is distributed open source
and
distributed is also escalated
uh and then as higher as a more
important as uh
uh
my favorite car yeah i'm just tired um
for explaining as higher let me uh
compare it to the
uh
to the uh
in fact uh traditional answers
in patch processing for example uh
you want to
uh you want to determine
which link is broken it is it is what
you want to find out you gather data
from your website for example load the
data into a dbms dbms as a dbms as a
your database and then execute a query
and determine if the link is broken or
article is uh
is trending it is the business this is
the requirement that you want to find
the data and you then you take action
then afterwards repeat it if you want to
say okay so after 10 minutes 20 minutes
6 minutes again you
uh
run the query it is what's happening
with traditional form but in a in
estimate as is to collect the same of
data you start a query and queries works
works on this
on this uh
in fact a sim of data and um
okay so
because i
i have just five minutes i it is what i
expected in picture
um espart
s par it is what does this for us and as
a very important tool i'm going to
explain a little bit you might know that
uh
uh in fact sr uh
developed in a uh
berkeley lab in 2009 in 2000 they become
open source in 2013 was given to the
apache project
2014 became a top-level project and now
until now this uh development is uh
going on
uh
uh
okay so uh a spark in b is based on rdds
rdds uh just uh are
some sort of data structure that expert
work on them they are speed over the
clusters or these
can can be made from a text file from
sql databases from nosql databases from
hdfs and
all a mapreduce function can be done can
can be
performed on on them also joining
and filtering and
all can be done on them and also
all of these actions uh
in spark is done in memory and this
already helps
helps that
to hide complexity
of
performance and what export does from
from the user
and uh here i just i'm
explaining
okay so soon okay so uh
dry uh driver and
driver and executor uh
are uh in fact uh main of a corrupt er
esport what happens that that program
execute a s4 context is built it's like
okay orchestrated this
organization just have a schedule just
have a just build a physical plan this
physical plan uh decide which tasks in
which order should should be executed
and these executors are done in
which
in each a word node and this workload
do the computation and the result will
come back to the will come back to the
derivative it is korov it is called
spark it is uh in fact a spark core and
on this the underscore
underscore there are some important
libraries like export sql spark stimuli
ml and graphics spark
streaming is
what we
use as a tool in our pipeline
and
for uh for esports
make and unbound the table make an
unbounded table from our data for
example each
every five second every n second is
n is config by you just a table is built
and then s4 sql is run in this table
also there are another and
an old one
old one ds streaming that is it it makes
rdd of uh
of micro batches so uh
for uh for example
so it's uh data is coming
so every five
seconds every five second you make a rdd
so you have a stream of rdds
rdd rdd html rd so you have extreme up
there you do some action on that so it's
work of developer is here is more
because the developer should uh write
some ufd on there but
but in the uh previous one a structured
data streaming
you build a uh you build a table so for
this table you can use as well
as park as well
you can use as far consumers so it's
much much easier
so it also is absolutely uh absolute
because you know
people use less and less
in the body data restore is okay so your
your data is processed your data your
data is processed uh when your data is
processed what happens after you analyze
data and discard the data
you analyze the data and push it to a
for example a
day
another sme platform or push it the same
swimming platform and it's later on
database and data and it and use it for
a offline access
it is
based on
each um
decision your in memory data is stored
should be should be designed and also
the last one
which i'm not going to
explain because the time is over but if
you have questions uh we will talk about
with data access fire depend when your
data is ready and you want and a client
a user a dashboard
an application needs data you need this
data access tire for uh in fact
providing data to the
client for example
okay thank you
[Applause]
i told you so fast so if you have a
question about details i'm ready to
answer thank you very much for a great
talk um so you mentioned the
yes and you mentioned the stock
streaming yeah so what is the technology
that you actually use because as far as
i know
[Music]
i use a spark we use in fact as part yes
but i find not because there are many
many shiny tools
you know and they are they are open
source so but but knife is a good uh
it's a good example that uh that it's
not it's
actually an ita tools because engineers
who etf
data for years they don't want to change
they don't want to change so that's why
we have as well as part okay so as an
iphone uh give them the same
sense
so that's good but i use a spark yeah of
course
you